six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller from the six
seven eight area code caller from six
seven eight
go ahead hey David my name is John I'm
from Atlanta and Michelle my question to
you is that based off of historical data
and polling data it is a high
probability that the Democrats may
retake the house and there's a slim
chance that the Democrats agree may we
take the Senate sure come this November
and while I'm a surface big that may
sound great should we as liberals be
concerned with the leadership will
undoubtably
lead the house in the Senecas if the
house turns blue Nancy Pelosi was
Speaker the house and we gotta say Chuck
Schumer be Senate Majority Leader and
those are like two centricity
corporately type of Democrats yes well
they will not will squander through a
time away try a piece president Trump
instead of by doing the policy that got
them elected such as like ending the
wars job creation infrastructure things
like that so should I be happy that this
is what happen our shot as we might be
worried so you should be worried it so
let's let's take it in two parts right
if Democrats are to take either the
House or Senate it's perfectly
reasonable to be concerned that the more
corporate centrist elements of the
Democratic Party would be the ones in
control legitimate concern and I share
the concern at the same time another two
years of a Republican House Senate and
Trump in the White House could prove
absolutely disastrous if you look at the
damage that has already been done by
Republicans who have been sort of
covered by the constant scandal of the
Donald Trump White House and you're
talking also about wasting time trying
to impeach Trump it's it's possible that
Robert Mulder will come back to us and
say there are reasons to start
impeachment proceedings if that's the
case yeah the Congress needs to do that
so having someone in there that's
worrying is important and I think
Congress can do two things at once so I
share your concern that the least
liberal elements of the Democratic Party
will be in control but I think it is the
most important thing that we can do
right now is get Republicans out of
power in the House and Senate in
November right yeah I don't wanna make
us much I didn't left
to be impeached if we find criminal
charges I'm all for being impeached but
yeah I don't want us we have a limited
amount of political capital for the
majority I don't want to squander away
when we could be doing progressive
ideals
listen kind of piggyback the second
question yeah what would you do I say no
no yeah in fact I'll piggyback off of
the other question while I do believe
federal you know position like the house
the Senate are important
you think Democrats also divided time
investing in war state offices because
in the current status quo majority of
state houses and you know cynics on top
can control majority the governorship
saw Republicans even like in blue states
like Maryland Massachusetts is remaining
Republican governors yeah so do
Democrats be focusing equal amount of
time on getting more blue state
positions of state posts equal is is
they should be focusing more time on
that I don't know about equal but I've
been talking about this this for years
John which is that Republicans do way
better at the lower levels and that
creates a really great bullpen to then
rise through the ranks and take control
of governorship so yeah absolutely they
need to be doing that and a lot of
Paulette the it's not true that all
politics is local but a lot of politics
is local and that's something that
Democrats just have been failing
miserably on John I appreciate the call
thank you thank you great to hear from
you